a couple of videos ago we learned that a
function that is a mapping from the set
X to the set Y is invertible invertible
if and only if and i'll write that is it
if with two F's if if and only if for
every y so let me write this down for
every I'll do this in yellow for every Y
that is a member of our codomain there
exists there exists a unique there
exists a unique and I'll make that a
little bit bold a unique X that is a
member of our domain such that such that
f of X F of this X is equal to this Y so
that's just saying that if I take my
domain right here that's X and then I
take a co domain here that is why we say
that the function f is invertible we say
that the function f is invertible and we
know what invertibility means it means
that there's this other function called
the inverse that can essentially if you
apply if you take that in composition
with f it's like taking the identity on
X or if you take F in composition with
it it's like taking the identity on Y it
we've done that multiple times so I
won't repeat that there we know what
invertibility means but we we learned
that if it's invertible if and only if
for every y here so you take any y here
any y that's a member of your co-domain
there exists a unique X such that f of X
is equal to that Y f of X is equal to
let me write it this way if this is an X
let's say that's an X naught f of X
naught would be equal to Y so this Y
would be equal to f of X naught you
apply the function here it's going to
map it to this point here it wouldn't be
invertible if you had this if you had
two members of X
mapping year that would break
invertibility if you had the situation
because then you wouldn't have the the
unique condition you have to have a
unique X that maps to this thing and
what I just drew here with this other
pink mapping we don't have a unique X
that maps to Y we have two x's that map
to Y now based on what I just told you
on that last video what does this mean
if we have a unique exit map to each Y
that means that we have to have a
one-to-one mapping that F has to be
one-to-one so let me write that so
another way of saying this is that F F
is one-to-one or injective injective so
if we have two guys mapping to the same
Y that would break down this condition
we wouldn't be one-to-one and we
couldn't say that there exists a unique
X such a unique x solution to this
equation
right here now the other part of this is
this for every Y you could pick any Y
here and you're going to there exists a
unique X that maps to that so I don't
care there cannot be some Y here let's
say that there's some Y here and no one
maps to that no one no one maps if
that's the case then we don't have then
we don't have our conditions for
invertibility so that would be not
invertible so everything in Y every
element of Y has to be mapped to all of
these guys have to be mapped to and they
can only be mapped to by one of the
elements of X everything here has to be
mapped to by a unique guy now in the
last video what did we call it when a
function maps to every element of your
codomain so this this every here what is
another way of saying that that a
function maps to every element of your
codomain on the last video I explained
that that notion is called a surjective
surjective or on to function so the
whole reason why I'm doing this video is
because I really just want to restate
the
condition for invertibility in in using
the vocabulary that I that I introduced
to you in the last video so given that
we can given that this statement for
every why that's a member of our
codomain there exists a X that maps to
it we could just say that f is
surjective f is surjective and then the
fact is if we just said that f is
surjective that means that everything
here is mapped to but it could be mapped
to maybe you know this person right here
could be mapped to by more than one
surjective doesn't doesn't by itself
make the condition that there's a unique
mapping from a member of X to that
element of Y so in order to get that in
order to satisfy the unique condition of
this condition for invertibility we have
to say that f is also on is also
injective is injective and obviously may
be the less formal terms for either of
these you call this on to and you could
call this one-to-one so using the
terminology that we learned in the last
video we can restate this condition for
invertibility we can say we can say that
a function that is a mapping from the
domain X to the codomain y is invertible
is invertible if and only if I'll write
it out and only if F is both surjective
surjective and injective and inject it
or we could have said that f is
invertible if and only if f is on - I
could write that here on - and
one-two-one one-two-one and these are
really just fancy ways of saying for
every Y in our codomain
there is a unique X that F maps to it
there isn't more than 1 and every Y does
get mapped to